the Jesse Smollett thing yeah I mean I
think we talked about it when I was in
on the book tours I mentioned it here
and there on social media yeah pop up on
my god there's Don sweating a little bit
well I was the first guy I think okay
maybe there was others they called it
out in comedy but I was the first guy
maybe let's call it in business and or
in politics maybe like the first guy was
something to lose they can't just be
like well I'm just a comedian it but you
know I was the first guy they got you
know cancelled on Instagram for being
like
okay guys like I see the outrage I see
that it's on Ellen in know every show
and every CNN and MSNBC and it was a 40
and I'm like I don't know guys like if
if someone really did this fry him right
okay I've said first thing all right if
but like really like this guy who's
making you know millions as an actor got
really hungry at 2:00 a.m. and on the
coldest night of the year in Chicago and
I built a building in Chicago I've spent
lots of time like he gets damn cold
uh-huh
decided to go to Subway I was like I
don't know today see you today you're
probably ordering seamless so I started
asking these questions I like your
problem starting with like okay let's
just start with Subway it's great like
you're gonna go out at minus 14 or
whatever it was at 2:00 a.m. to get us
up like your order seamless that's what
you do like you're pretty famous down
junior at 2:00 a.m. on a very cold night
stealing when would you walk to a subway
now I would nine something else to eat
get a home I can either you know and
then it was like okay so yeah two guys
white guys white supremacists problem in
in Mogga hats oh yeah in downtown
Chicago mmm-hmm also on the coldest
night of the year like that's who I am
yeah 2:00 a.m. and and bundling and they
didn't get shot they managed to live
long enough to find Jesse Smollett
because they know who Jesse Smollett is
because obviously Empire has a huge
audience of white supremacists yes you
know I mean you know they obviously know
who this guy is and they were taking a
chance that he'd be out at 2:00 in the
morning on the coldest night of the year
going into subway they were it's so much
foresight huh
that they decided to bring a twine noose
yes you know breaking strength of about
two pounds and a bucket of bleach and
I'm just saying man trust me I get it
like I was like I I know that I could
this could go so wrong for me yeah if
I'm wrong but I'm saying can
any reasonable person meaning if it
wasn't 2019 you know and you went back
to a reasonable time in history yeah
would you look at this fact set and be
like oh yeah no-brainer like this
definitely happened or would you be like
give me a freakin break you like you'd
call [ __ ] so fast and so I did and I
was like I just don't see this hat and
then all of a sudden well the cops are
saying that he won't give us the phone
and then he's saying he's upset that
they're actually investigating it this
hard I'm saying wait a minute so used
telling me he wanted the best of both
worlds he wanted them to actually not
investigate so then he could [ __ ] and
moan and say oh they didn't even look at
you know this case of obvious white
supremacy yeah you know and then you see
the connection with the DA and the
Obamas and they're not gonna pursue it
on Fox yeah I'm saying oh my god like
this is insane but meanwhile Instagram
is doing this all these like left-wing
things Donald Trump jr. spreading racist
conspiracy
I wasn't spreading anything I asked a
freaking question do you know when that
first happened my first day did we get
instincts as people you see something
and you're like that doesn't feel it
feels like [ __ ] and but it's like
it's hard to come right out and say
immediately cuz you like God if this guy
did get attack today yeah my side and
you get it wrong it's over you finished
Roseanne had a stupid tweet her career
is over the other guy's like he'll get a
starring role on his next show despite
the fact that he literally tried to
create a race war
try to better you know in try it no hits
right what do you do and I imagine they
too caught you know two young white kids
that maybe fit that description imagine
they did that just happen to be in the
area like you know extreme coincidence
but it happens right
especially a bucket of bleach because
that's how ridiculous the story was but
like imagine they felt like someone like
that they would have destroyed these
people and he wouldn't have come out and
said I was just kidding like you know
that's some scary [ __ ] and that it's
happening and that this is a mainstream
guy who's out there with all these
left-wing politicians and he's hanging
out with the Obamas and he's like you
know what this is how I'm gonna get more
money in my next thing because I'm gonna
make myself the victim of I'm not saying
that racism isn't a real problem okay
like it is it's just not the answer to
every problem that every person on the
Left has that yo well you know that
doesn't add up that is math obviously
racist we like stop it's the accusations
enough doesn't disservice to those who
are actually affected by it because now
you hear racist and you're like okay
like roll your eyes move on like it's
probably [ __ ] and it's not always
[ __ ] it's just when you use it as
sort of the easy button of left-wing
politics like I have no answer for that
therefore racist it doesn't work anymore